des femmes en guerre des combattantes
civile qui fabrique des cocktails
molotov artisanaux
nous sommes dans une école transformée
en atelier clandestin
le lieu est tenu secret pour des raisons
de sécurité bouteille et mèche de
fortune 1 mais fort de guerre qui
rappellent des scènes de la première
guerre mondiale cette femme à son mari
sur le front
en étant ici je l'aide
même si j'aimerais lui être avec lui sur
la ligne de front pour jeter cet ennemi
hors de notre pays
voici comment les civils ukrainien
utilisent ces armes de fortune contre
les blindés russes
quitte à se brûler
retour à l'atelier 1500 cocktails
molotov fabriqué par jour cinq lieux de
production sur toute la ville une
véritable industrie
à l'extérieur les alarmes retentisse la
ville de nieppe rossi vit dans la peur
des bombardements
ces réfugiés ukrainien de l'intérieur
vont se mettre à l'abri
plus tard toujours indignés pro toujours
dans le secret c'est tout très fort de
guerre dans cet atelier de couture des
stylistes fabrique des gilets pare
balles
la plaque de métal est envoyé par un
autre groupe de résistance et les tester
à balles réelles par un troisième but
à l'extérieur est cette fois au grand
jour la construction de centaines de
barrages autour de la ville sur tous les
grands axes des pneus mais aussi du bois
pour se réchauffer pendant des mois si
nécessaire
nous allons détruire cet ennemi qu'ils
soient russes biélorusses ou je ne sais
quelle région pro russe
nous gagnerons
gloire à l'ukraine
le drapeau ukrainien comme un défi lancé
aux russes
il semble en fait que tout le pays se
soient mobilisés une incroyable
effervescence pour lutter contre les
forces de la deuxième puissance
militaire mondiale
voilà donc